- Hello everyone, my name is Lily
and I'm here to announce
a brand new series
on Evan's channel called Unlocking Lily.
So I had my first sit-down with Evan
about a year and a half
ago as an instructor
at his dance studio.
During the meeting, he told me that
he really liked me and he wanted
to start some sort of business with me.
So my first thought
was, wow, he is so nice.
And what an amazing
confidence-booster for me.
Then my second thought was,
I don't have a business plan.
Oh my gosh, I don't even
have a business idea.
I've never thought about
becoming an entrepreneur,
I don't think that's
something I'm supposed
to do with my life.
So that's where it kind of ended.
I went on to continue to
teach at his dance studio,
but that thought always remained
in the back of my mind.
So it was fine, things progressed on.
I continued to teach at his dance school.
As I got to know him better
and we had more sit-downs,
I decided that maybe I'll
let him know about my dream.
My dream is to go on stage one day
and be a speaker, but I have no idea how.
I don't know when, I don't
know what I'm going to say,
I have no experience, but I knew
this is something I
wanted to do with my life,
but I just didn't know how to get there.
So last week, he decided to
do something rather crazy.
He offered me $50,000
to quit my full-time job
that I had been at for 12
years to pursue my dream
of public speaking full-time.
As he was mentioning this to me,
I already made up my mind.
He doesn't know that.
I already knew that I would say yes.
But of course, I didn't
want to verbally commit
knowing that there's so many things
that could go wrong.
Ever since I became an adult at 21,
at 20, I always been financially secure.
That's something that was very important
to me growing up.
For me to take this leap of faith,
it means that I may not
be financially secure.
I may not be able to provide a life
for me and my husband that I've always
promised that I will.
And that was my biggest concern.
I needed to talk to my husband before
I actually said anything to him.
But even though I knew this is something
that I wanted to do.
That is the only thing
I ever really wanted
to do in my life more than anything else.
So I spoke to my husband and he was
so incredibly supportive and he knew
that I needed to do this.
It's really now or never.
If I didn't do this now, I will live
and die never pursuing my dream.
So I accepted his offer at midnight
that day, I sent him a message,
and the next day, I told my boss
that I'll be leaving my
job, that I have been
with the company for 12 years.
And it was really, really hard
for me because I have been so happy
at my job, I love the people there,
I loved my boss, she's wonderful.
For me to say that I'm going to be leaving
this secure, wonderful job that I've been
at for 12 years with all the friends
I created, to tell them that I'm going to
be doing this because
I'm going to be pursuing
my dream of public speaking, it was
crazy, crazy for me.
You see, we don't have a plan.
The plan is to make a plan.
I'm taking a giant leap of faith with Evan
and stepping into the unknown.
But I know it's going to work out.
And we're going to bring
you on this journey.
That's why it's called Unlocking Lily.
As I learn, grow, make mistakes,
have wins, you're going to come with me.
You're going to even sit in on
my mentoring meetings with Evan.
My practice sessions, my
confessional thoughts,
and watch me conquer my dream.
And I hope I see me go for it.
It inspires you as well.
And at the very least, cheer me on
because I'm going to need your support.
I'm going to need a shoulder to cry on
when things are tough.
I'm going to need to celebrate with you
when I have my victories.
This is going to be a weekly series
on Evan's channel where I'm going
to film and I hope you tune in.
And if you have any questions,
suggestions, please
leave it in the comments.
I promise you I'm paying attention
and I will take everything to heart.
So stay tuned for
Unlocking Lily Episode 1.
Thank you so much Believe Nation.
I am so incredibly excited and grateful
and honored, and I hope
to see you very soon.